We can’t sit at home waiting
for news about adoptions.
Ahh.
What?
We’re never gonna find a kid.
They go so quickly.
This is you.
What?
You took too long again.
Yeah, but it’s difficult choosing
a child from a photograph,
isn’t it? You wanna get in there
and kick the tires a little bit.
Are you set on a girl?
Girls tell you what they're feeling.
They know how to ask for help.
You just sit on a sofa hugging a
cushion, sighing louder and louder
until someone asks
you what’s wrong.
Boys are uncomplicated.
You alright then?
Yeah... yeah...
You?
What is the one thing that we
need to be able to take these kids?
Money, experience,
preparation.
I know it’s hard.
It’s a mammoth
undertaking
and I should know
I brought up two happy,
friendly, well-adjusted children
out of four.
Please, I’m having enough
trouble getting my own family
without keeping your
one functioning too.
Okay fine. We need to
talk about childcare.
I’ve been babysitting.
It’s not even called
that when they're yours.
Just don’t let them
be fussy eaters.
My friend Clayton only ate
toast until he was twelve
and now he’s
really into S&M.
Has this helped?
Massively.
What if it changes things?
Whatever happens,
we'll be messing
things up together.
You don’t want to
meet at this stage.
It could jeopardize
the adoption.
Just pretend you’re visiting the
school on professional business.
If we’re being other people,
should we do accents?
I can do American.
Show me.
Well howdy partner.
I’m going to stop you right there.
It’s absolutely perfect.
What?
On your last visit
to the school,
did you happen to see a
strange American woman
bothering the children?
What?
No.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah look, she says lovely to see
you both and I’ll be in touch soon.
Don't do that!